foreign
welcome to Hannity 18 days and counting
and coming up tonight we're going to
bring you the latest polls as
Republicans now continue to gain
momentum even in some of the most
liberal areas of the country including
right here in New York and tonight after
two years with Democrats in control of
the house the Senate the White House
Americans are less safe they are less
secure they have less money they have
more debt their energy costs and grocery
costs are through the roof more than
two-thirds of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck some are using
credit cards just to make ends meet for
the bare necessities now the number one
killer of Young Americans in this
country is now fentanyl that is pouring
across the wide open Southern border of
Joe Biden now deaths are caused from
drug overdoses now they're higher than
ever before oh and don't forget
according to Biden we are now the
closest we've ever been to a worldwide
nuclear Armageddon closest since the
Cuban Missile Crisis but the economy is
strong as hell he said and there's no
crisis at the border now this fateful
two-year experiment with Democrats in
charge of everything it has been an
unmitigated disaster but according to
Joe everything is just swell great and
we should all be thanking him take a
look
we're starting to see some of the good
news on the economy the price of gas the
pump is coming down look at what I've
inherited and what I've done and they're
going to raise big Farmer's profits
they're doing fine big Pharma they're
not hurting at all
and they're going to raise your health
insurance premiums
it's mega mega
trickle down
mega mega trickle down the kind of
policies that have failed the country
before and I'll fail it again
okay let's look at what Joe inherited
energy Independence America was a net
exporter of energy Joe Biden ended that
two dollar a gallon gasoline it's now
more than double inflation under two
percent one point four percent to be
precise it is now over eight percent
interest rates were well 2.7 to 3
percent for a 30-year fixed rate
mortgage it's now over seven percent a
booming housing market that is now in a
precipitous decline a border that was
Secure that is now seeing a record we've
never seen this in the history of the
country record levels of illegal
immigration the less agenda is such a
failure many top Democrats they are now
attempting an election year conversion
it's fun to watch but um it's actually
all a lie take a look hell yes we're
going to take your AR-15 your AK-47 I'm
not interested in taking anything from
anyone what I want to make sure that we
do is defend the Second Amendment yeah
fracking no I I don't support word
fracking at all and I never have I
support fracking I support the uh the
energy security that we should have in
in the United States no more drilling
including offshore no ability for the
oil industry to continue to drill period
my Administration has not stopped or
slowed U.S oil production
quite the opposite
Democrats simply they are ruining this
country and then lying to your face or
hiding in their basement bunkers just
like Joe did in 2020 and of course their
cheerleaders in the media mob they are
allowing all of this to happen they're
not asking any tough questions and Joe
and his radical climate socialists could
just be honest and apologize and correct
course and say oh the era of big
government is over the end of welfare as
we know it like Clinton did but that
will never happen once known as Capitol
Hill's dumbest Senator Joe Biden would
rather lie through his teeth and double
down on failure instead although in his
defense it's really not totally clear
that Joe even knows what's going on for
example here he is once again trying to
explain why Democrats are shutting him
on the campaign Trail getting very testy
about it now listen closely and see if
you can make sense of what Joe is
actually trying to say
Kim Ryan in Ohio said he doesn't want
you there Warnock said wouldn't say do
you think they're making a mistake no
they're about 16 there I've already done
in 48 and a lot more grass another 20 or
so I'm gonna be going
let me make it simple Joe they don't
want to be anywhere near you you can go
spend all of your time in your rocking
chair by the Beach in Delaware and
that'll make every other candidate you
know give them a sigh of relief they'll
be happy about it and while you're at it
by the way why don't you take your good
friend John fetterman with you before he
lets every single convicted murderer and
rapist out of jail because as lieutenant
governor fetterman your friend the only
one guy that was dumb enough to want to
campaign with you he voted to release
dozens of convicted first-degree
murderers along with dozens of other
violent felons and fetterman also fully
supports zero bail laws the legalization
of hard drugs he wants Pennsylvania
taxpayers to pay for safe injection
sites for heroin addicts and needless to
say the biggest city in Pennsylvania is
now one of the most violent places on
Earth the City of Brotherly Love
Philadelphia Now setting record after
record for murder arm robbery theft all
thanks in part to policies like Joe
Biden's and John fetterman's of course
in the case of fetterman he's not acting
alone the guy he endorsed for D.A in
Philly guy by the name of Larry krasner
hates Prosecuting violent offenders and
thanks to him well countless murderers
they're now roaming the streets and
recently he vacated the sentence of a
guy that was convicted of a 2012 murder
led him out of prison that person is now
a suspect in another deadly shooting
what a shock can you actually believe
that now in this upside down world run
by these progressives and free the
convicted murderers if you're a
hard-working taxpaying law-abiding
American citizen uh I guess you're
actually immoral and by the way and bad
but if you're a violent career criminal
you're revered and protected hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will will not get it
anywhere else